STEVE VINTER: Hi, and
welcome to Boston Common here
in Google Cambridge.
It's great to have you here.
And my name is Steve Vinter.
We're here for the second
meeting of the Thought Leaders
at Google Cambridge program.
And this event is in
partnership with Talks at Google
and it's live
streamed on YouTube,
as well as being available
to Googlers here locally.
And so it's great to have this
talk go out over the waves.
The point of this
series is really
to get people in the area who
are thought leaders in industry
and academia, and I
think today's guests
are a great example of that.
I'd like to thank
Kara Miller, host
and Executive Editor of
WGBH's Innovation Hub,
for coming back and
leading today's discussion,
and welcome Dr. Kerry Emanuel
from MIT, who's an atmosphere
physicist, or scientist,
as I said, from MIT,
and specializes in
hurricane physics.
So sometimes you're a
hurricane physicist as well.
Is that true?
Does that work?
Good.
I think what's been
really interesting
about global weather
change is how
unified the scientific
community has
been in speaking out about this.
And in addition to Dr.
Emanuel's research,
he's been a big part
of communicating
with the general
public with his book
two years ago about "What We
Know About Climate Change,"
which addresses both the
scientific issues and also
some of the political challenges
of having this issue be
understood and dealt
with by our society.
I'd like to remind
other Googlers here
that there's a
Dory for questions
that you'd like to have
Dr. Emanuel answer.
And let me turn it over to Kara.
Thank you very much.
KARA MILLER: Thank you.
And just like last
time, I really
want this to be a conversation.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit with Kerry,
but then we want to open things
up to out in the audience
and into the broader
audience watching.
So definitely be thinking
of questions that you have.
There could be,
probably, no better day
than this, because I
woke up this morning,
looked at the "New
York Times" online
and saw that there was a huge
new study about climate change
that was being published
sort of looking at Americans'
perceptions of whether
climate change is real,
and looking forward
to the 2016 election,
would they want to
vote for somebody
who wants to do something
about it, or who says,
no, it's a hoax.
And what you see is
these huge numbers.
The only thing I can compare
it to in terms of movement
is, if you look at the numbers
in support of gay marriage
over, let's say,
20 years, and you
see sort of a massive shift.
And the other thing you
see with those numbers,
as well as with
these numbers, is
that younger people
and older people
are considerably different
in terms of where they stand.
So older people are
still much more cautious
about climate change, not
sure that it's happening.
Younger people are much more
convinced that it is happening
and rank it in terms
of, this is something
that's very important
to me, and we
have to do something about it.
So against that backdrop
we're here today.
And actually, Kerry,
I'm wondering,
if that's the perception
out in the world
and things are
starting to change,
and you really can
see those numbers
over 10, 20 years, and
really the sort of mass
of public opinion
shift-- if you take us
inside the world of climate
scientists, where are they?
How do they look
out at this world,
and in at their own world in
terms of what's happening?
KERRY EMANUEL: Well,
it's very difficult
to be a climate scientist
today, look at all the evidence
that we have in front of us, and
not be at least mildly alarmed.
So what almost all of
my colleagues and I
see when we look
at the evidence is
risk, a rather substantial
risk to future generations.
And that risk has uncertainty,
as almost all risk does, almost
by definition.
If you look out at
the high tail of risk,
that truly is alarming.
And that's the picture
that we have to deal with.
KARA MILLER: So
have you seen-- has
there, in the last year
or two, been things
that you would point to in
terms of climate science
moving that you think
we should know about,
but maybe that those
intricacies don't
get communicated to
the general public?
KERRY EMANUEL: Well, there's
no sort of sudden turning point
here.
We are gradually getting
better and better
at measuring the earth.
That's one improvement.
So for example, over
the last decade,
we have been able to do
something that's really
a breakthrough,
which is to measure
the ocean below the surface
much more accurately.
It seems a little bit crazy,
but a lot of scientists
will tell you we know more
about the surface of Mars
than we do about our oceans.
And it's simply a
matter of ocean water
being very difficult to measure.
You can send a probe down, but
you can't transmit by radio
up through the water.
So the answer turned out to
be robotic floats, little baby
submarines, you might think of
them, but they're automated.
They go down, they make
measurements, they come back,
they transmit the
measurements by satellite.
That's one example of a
technological development
that has allowed
us to understand,
for example, the heat
content of the ocean
and how it's changing much
more accurately than we
were able to do before.
KARA MILLER: And what are
climate models telling you?
I mean, can you take us
forward 10, 20, 30, 40 years?
What's your sense of
where we're headed?
KERRY EMANUEL: Well, let me
preface this my answer to that
by saying that although climate
models get a lot of press
and attention, and in fact they
are an important tool that we
use, we were concerned
about this problem
long before there could be
such a thing as climate models.
So the Swedish chemist
Svante Arrhenius
was worried about
what would happen
if we increased carbon
dioxide, and what
it would do to the planet at
the end of the 19th century,
long before digital computers.
And his estimate of what
doubling carbon dioxide would
do to the global mean
surface temperature
is well within
the limits of what
has been estimated, largely on
the basis of computer models,
in the last few years.
So models are big,
complicated, and there
are a lot of approximations,
somewhat offset by the fact
that there are many of
them around the world.
So there are independent
groups trying to do things.
So what we see is an
envelope, going forward.
And in the next
100 years, assuming
that nothing happens and we
keep burning fossil fuels
at the ever-increasing
rate that we're doing it,
we're looking at doubling
the atmospheric CO2
content from preindustrial
values by mid-century,
and at least tripling it
by the end of the century.
By the time we get
to tripling it,
even the middle of that risk
curve looks frightening to us.
KARA MILLER: So
does that move mean
that we're all moving to Canada?
I mean, does it
mean that there's
going to be a massive relocation
of the population northward?
KERRY EMANUEL: Well, I think we
have to think about two things.
What you're talking about,
we would call adaptation.
How are people going
to adapt to this?
And let's take a recent example
that may or may have nothing
to do with climate change,
is this big blizzard we had.
Now if you looked
at the newspaper,
some of the people that
got really hard hit
are down in Scituate.
They had huge waves.
KARA MILLER: Right,
right on the ocean.
KERRY EMANUEL: And
they have had before,
and there's a lot of damage.
And I would bet
you that something
will happen the next time.
I don't think they're just going
to rebuild there the same way.
Either they won't
rebuild there-- there's
even talk about the state
buying that property, which
has happened elsewhere--
or they'll build them
on tall stilts, which is
another way to do that.
And I think this
is what happens.
New York got pounded
by Sandy, and they're
making a lot of
changes for that.
Now as time goes on, if that's
all that were to happen,
we would gradually adapt,
and the adaptation is local.
It depends on where you are.
Coastlines one thing,
inland agriculture, forests.
All of that get to be
more and more expensive.
And people become
more and more wistful
that we weren't doing more to
mitigate the problem, that is,
to actually stop
it from happening.
KARA MILLER: Well, people talked
about after Sandy building
multi-billion dollar sea
walls in the New York area.
Do you anticipate that
happening because they
don't want another
hurricane like Sandy?
KERRY EMANUEL: Well,
Michael Bloomberg,
who was the mayor at
the time Sandy hit,
interestingly
enough, was already
well-engaged with the
climate change problem
when that happened.
And the city has
undertaken a very serious,
comprehensive study
of its options.
Now it, as a city, can't do
too much globally to mitigate,
but it can adapt,
and so sea walls
is one of the options
they're looking at.
There are other
interesting ones.
It was a surprise
to me to find out
that 100 years
ago, Manhattan was
a major exporter of oysters.
And they were very
special oysters
that were delicious and
widely sought after,
which is why they basically
went away, one of the reasons.
Oyster beds that used to
surround southern Manhattan
were a big mitigating
factor in storm surges,
which is what happened in Sandy.
They actually slow it down.
So one of the options
New York is looking at
is reintroducing oyster beds.
There are all kinds of
proposals on the table
and it hasn't entirely
been sorted out yet.
KARA MILLER: So I want to zero
in on this hurricane thing
because, as Steve said,
hurricanes are your thing.
So talk a little bit about--
let's talk a little bit
about the past.
What have we seen,
just up to now?
If now is the
stopping point, what
have we actually seen
in terms of hurricanes
over the last several decades?
Where have they gone?
Have they become more
numerous, stronger?
What's happening?
KERRY EMANUEL: Well, I'll
try to answer your question.
But I have to tell you
first that we don't do,
and we haven't done a very
good job measuring hurricanes
historically.
In the Atlantic we think we have
a reasonably good record going
back to 1970, which
isn't that long ago.
And then the record
starts to deteriorate.
We have a reasonable
understanding of US landfalling
hurricanes, and
Caribbean hurricanes
going back much
further than that.
You have to understand
that only about 11%
of the world's
tropical cyclones,
which is the generic
term for a hurricane,
occur in the Atlantic,
even though they
get 99% of the press.
Most of them occur in the
Indian and Pacific Oceans.
And we've done a
perfectly terrible job,
and are still doing a
terrible job, measuring them.
So with that as a preface,
what we've seen in
the Atlantic is a
general increase
in levels of activity from
early in the last century
to around the 1950s or so, and
then a fairly steep decline
from the '50s to the 1980s, and
then a fairly steep rise, then.
Now I'm not talking--
of course there's
a lot of noise
from year to year.
For example, last year was
very quiet in the Atlantic.
But that's the sort
of decadal trend.
And we're trying to
understand why that's so.
And we are quite
sure that it has
to do with some kind
of climate signals,
including, possibly,
global warming.
But there's more
going on than that.
KARA MILLER: So explain
to me how climate change
does enter into hurricanes and
enters into how strong they are
and where they are.
KERRY EMANUEL: Interestingly
enough, hurricanes
owe their existence to the fact
that the earth has a greenhouse
effect.
And broadly speaking,
the greenhouse effect
means that it's very
hard for the oceans
to lose heat by radiating
it directly to space.
And so they compensate for
that by evaporating seawater.
Seawater's always evaporating,
which cools the ocean.
And so you have to maintain
an evaporative potential
between the atmosphere
and the ocean.
It's that potential,
interestingly enough,
that drives hurricanes.
And we realized back
in the late 1980s
that if you put more greenhouse
gas in the atmosphere,
this evaporatorative
potential has to go up.
It's just basic physics.
You don't need big
models for that.
And so the potential for
hurricanes, in some sense,
goes up.
And that potential largely
governs how intense
they get, but doesn't tell
you, oddly enough, very
much about how
frequent storms are.
So a lot more people
have gotten-- a lot
more scientists have gotten
interested in this issue
since I first published a
paper in the late 1980s drawing
attention to the
potential increase
in hurricane activity
owing to global warming.
And the consensus now
is that the frequency
of the very high category
events-- which historically
have completely dominated
hurricane damage
and mortality-- the
frequency of those events
will probably go up,
and there's evidence
that it is going up in
many parts of the world.
But we don't know as
much about the frequency
of weak hurricanes, which
dominate the numbers.
So if you like to
count, if that's
what you're interested in doing,
we don't know much about that.
There are 85 tropical cyclones
around the world every year,
and that number appears to be
quite stable at the moment.
But the storms that we care
about as a society, the really
intense ones, theory,
models, and observations,
to some example,
suggest that those
are going up rather
substantially
as we warm the planet.
KARA MILLER: So if Governor
Cuomo from New York,
if Governor Christie from
New Jersey got you in a room
and said, we really
need to talk to you.
Clearly Hurricane Sandy
was really expensive,
very traumatic for
people in our states.
Give us a sense.
Is this something we should now
be expecting every few years?
What do we do about it?
Is there anything to be done?
You're the expert.
Help us figure out
what the plan is here.
KERRY EMANUEL: So as
far as we can make out
from several different
independent studies, given
the climate of the last
century, the 20th century,
the history of hurricanes
and models of hurricanes,
Sandy was an event
whose intensity
in New York, of a surge
magnitude in New York
you might have expected
once every 700 years.
In other words, it was a
very rare kind of storm.
And that's comforting.
We're not likely to
have another Sandy soon.
But you know, the
fact that we had
one doesn't make it any
less probable to have one
the next year.
But we have also
done studies where
we look at various
different climate models
and we make inferences about
hurricane activity in them.
And that suggests that the
frequency of that kind of event
might go to more
like every 200 years
or so toward the
end of the century.
But I have to say that
all along, the US is
a bit of a special case
here, because the US has
a terrible, terrible hurricane
problem even without climate
change, which is that
we have in place--
and this is well known in my
field and in many fields--
a lot of policies that
very strongly subsidize
and encourage people to
build flimsy structures
in dangerous places.
And it's something you hardly
see anywhere else in the world.
And if we don't conquer that
problem, which again, exists
independently of climate
change, climate change
will make that even worse.
KARA MILLER: Is that problem
being conquered at all?
KERRY EMANUEL: No.
Congress tried a
couple of years ago
to address this in overhauling
one big piece of that subsidy,
which was the federal
flood insurance program.
So if you live in
a flood plain--
and that includes the coast--
that covers storm surges,
you can buy fairly inexpensive
insurance to cover property.
And it's not priced
according to the risk.
So it doesn't cost
you that much less
if you get the insurance
in some place that's
comparatively safe.
So it underwrote it.
And what Congress did was
to pass a law mandating
that the insurance premiums
reflect the actual risk, which
seems like no brainer, right?
That's what insurance should do.
Guess what they
just did last fall?
They repealed it.
There was so much
howling from people
who live on the coast, who
typically are wealthier
than the average American--
oh, my premium went up,
it's now half as much as my
car, what are we going to do,
the sky's falling.
They made such a racket that
Congress basically repealed it.
So my take is, we're not going
anywhere on this, not until we
have some really
colossal events that
force the government's hand.
KARA MILLER: So
let's look at-- we
talked a lot about the problem.
Let's look at the other
side for a few minutes,
potential solutions.
Obviously there is the
sort of political side
of things, which we
can get into later.
But talk a little bit about, are
there technological solutions?
Are scientists
working on solutions
that you think have any sort of
chance of really making headway
on a pretty serious problem?
KERRY EMANUEL: I'm very
optimistic on this front.
I think technology is more
likely to produce results
sooner than politics, at
least in this country.
That's not saying a lot.
KARA MILLER: What?
KERRY EMANUEL: Everybody-- I
think everybody in this room
probably is aware of the
technology developments in wind
and solar power.
The solar cells have become
more efficient, a lot lighter.
I just had solar cells put
on a roof of a house we have
in Maine, a summer house,
and it's been wonderful.
And maybe we can
do about 40 or 50%
of our electrical power needs.
And unless there's a big
breakthrough in storage
of power, that's about the limit
because of the intermittency
of sunlight and wind.
It's not a panacea.
And so a lot of the effort's
going to focus on baseload.
But I think there are some
really, really interesting
solutions.
But there are a lot of political
and social, cultural barriers
to those.
So one of them is just
simply capturing the CO2
from the atmosphere and
burying it, putting it
in solid or liquid form and
burying it in the earth.
And the Canadians and the US
and some countries in Europe
are experimenting with this.
We know how to do it.
It's a little bit
too expensive now.
But I think if we had a
reasonable carbon tax in place
and we didn't have such
a low price for petroleum
as we do right at
this moment, I think
that would become
much more attractive.
So with natural
gas and petroleum,
there's not that much
downside to burning the stuff,
actually, if you can take
the really dangerous things,
the particulates and the carbon
dioxide out of it and bury it.
So that's a promising
piece of technology.
The other is next
generation nuclear fission,
which we also sort
of know how to do.
And it raises a specter
in people's minds
of bombs and things.
The fact is, we shouldn't be
operating '60s-generation power
plants.
We're generating
dangerous waste.
There's a lot of
risk of proliferation
of the fuels-- of the waste
for weapons and so forth.
But we do know how to build
safe, passively safe, much less
expensive, far more efficient
reactors based on thorium
and using molten salt as the
medium that carries the fuel.
We've actually known how to
do that since the 1950s or so.
And there are all
kinds of groups,
including here in Cambridge,
that have sprouted up
to try to take
advantage of that.
So that could really satisfy
the baseload power in a very
environmentally friendly way,
produce far less toxic waste
than '60s-generation power
plants or coal plants.
KARA MILLER: I'll
be the skeptic here.
You know, you talked about
having potentially a carbon
tax to fund some initiatives.
I remember one time
interviewing two economists, one
who'd served in the Clinton
administration, one who'd
served in the George
W Bush administration.
You would suppose they would
agree on, like, nothing.
They didn't agree on much, but
one thing they did agree on
was that we should
have a carbon tax.
And I said, wait, you both agree
we should have a carbon tax?
And they were like,
yeah, most economists
really do agree
on that, wherever
they are on the
political spectrum.
And I said, then you do
you think it could happen?
And they're like, no.
It will never happen.
So if we're relying on money
coming from a carbon tax
to fund some of the potentially
promising initiatives
that you talked about,
but that's never coming,
does that concern you?
Does that concern
you that those things
won't get off the ground?
And then you sort of couple
that with, oil is dirt cheap,
and it's so hard to
compete with that right
now for any other
alternative fuel.
KERRY EMANUEL: To just
take your last point first,
the cheapness of oil is a
very short term transient.
I mean, we're not
going to see it
this cheap for a long
time, maybe a few years,
optimistically.
Well, optimistically
or pessimistically
depending on your point of view.
KARA MILLER: Yes, but people
in renewables would say,
every time this
kind of thing comes,
it sort of cleans out a
whole bunch of startups
that are trying to do
something, and then they
just get killed, and then--
KERRY EMANUEL: That's right.
And in fact, I read an
editorial a couple weeks ago
very sensibly saying, this is
the time to do a carbon tax,
is when it's cheap.
So my take on this,
having read a lot of it--
I'm not an economist,
I'm not an expert--
is that the beauty
of the carbon taxis
it would accelerate a
lot of this technology.
I don't think its
absence will mean
this will never happen,
on the other hand.
So one of the
things I argue when
I have to argue with
Congress, which occasionally I
do about this, you know,
this is going to happen.
There's going to
be carbon capture.
There's going to be
next generation fission.
Really the question is whether
we develop this technology here
and sell it abroad,
or whether we're later
forced to buy it from, say,
the Chinese, who are developing
these things quite independently
of what we decide to do.
So I think the
technology will happen.
But it could happen a lot
sooner, and perhaps more
efficiently, if we did
have a mechanism that
encouraged innovation.
And that's really
what the carbon tax--
you know, there
was also, earlier,
the cap and trade
solution, which came out
of a conservative think tank.
So it is an area
of economics where
people from a broad
political spectrum agree.
KARA MILLER: I want to take
your questions in two minutes.
So there are-- there's a
microphone here and here.
And then, as Steve said, you
can also submit your questions
and they will be asked if you
don't want to do it yourself,
or if you're watching remotely.
So get ready with
your questions,
and I'll turn to them
in just one minute.
And one last thing
before we do that.
The solar and wind potential.
It's interesting.
It really depends on who
you ask how much potential.
Obviously Germany has just
gone sort of full-throated
into solar.
It's not a particularly sunny
country, but they went for it.
But I've talked to
people who said,
you know, the fact that
we have no good way
to store solar and wind
is a serious problem,
because the wind is
not always blowing
and the sun is not
always shining.
And you are never able
to really wean yourself
off that sort of
central power plant,
burning coal or whatever
they're bringing
to give you electricity.
KERRY EMANUEL: Well, I mean, the
real probably optimal solution
is somewhere between
those two extremes.
And Germany is actually, in
some ways a good, in some ways
a bad example.
I think they got up to 20
or 25% of their power, which
is remarkable because,
as you point out,
Germany isn't a
particularly sunny place.
But that's a pretty hard limit.
They're going to find it
very hard to go beyond that.
Now they also, at the same
time, after Fukushima,
decided, I think very
unwisely, in my view,
to decommission their
nuclear power plants.
The reason I think
that's unwise is
to compensate for
the baseload, they're
building coal-fired
power plants, which
is what you don't want to do, as
fast as they can, lots of them,
in Germany.
And, by the way,
they're buying power
from Switzerland and
France, who, guess what,
generate it with
nuclear reactors.
So they're not really
getting off nuclear.
They're just putting it in
someone else's backyard.
But any sort of-- today,
looking at the technology today,
any sensible power
generation will
have a lot of
renewables in the mix.
And it largely depends
on where you are.
If you're in the
desert southwest,
you can do an awful
lot with solar.
If you're in Seattle, well--
but that's a different problem.
The sun doesn't shine as much.
If you're on the coast
of Maine or Nantucket,
you can generate a
lot of wind power.
But if you're down
in Louisiana, not.
So it depends on
where you are, too.
Question right here.
AUDIENCE: So one of
the nightmare scenarios
that I read about with global
climate change is the methane
clathrates at the
bottom of the ocean,
or the carbon that's sequestered
in the tundra, and worries
about, as the climate warms
these sources of carbon
could be released fairly
rapidly and kind of dramatically
change the whole chemistry.
What are your thoughts about
that sort of nightmare Scenario
KERRY EMANUEL: That's
an interesting question.
Methane is molecule by
molecule a much more effective
greenhouse gas than
carbon dioxide,
but there's a lot less
of it in the atmosphere.
But its lifetime in
the atmospheres a lot
less than CO2.
It's decades as opposed
to millennia, basically.
So as the tundra begins to
thaw, there is methane locked up
in it and it's released
through the atmosphere,
and that is a positive
feedback on the system.
In the latest IPCC report
there was an attempt
to do an inventory of
that, and it came up
with it being not such a
big problem quantitatively.
But we do know, to take
a somewhat broader view
of your question, that when we
study the climate going back
millions of years-- particularly
the last few hundred
thousand years we have good
records from ice scores--
we see very rapid
changes of climate
that we don't understand.
I mean, we sort of
understand, for example,
why there are ice ages.
We understand that
very well, actually.
It has to do with varying
amounts of insulation
from changes in the
earth's orbit, which
are very predictable changes.
But there are sudden jumps
that we don't particularly
understand.
And the sort of thing that
keeps us awake at night
is the Donald Rumsfeld
unknown unknowns.
It's that we know enough
to know that we don't
know a lot about
the climate system.
And the possibility of a sudden
flip to a different state
can't be ruled out
because we see it
in the paleoclimate records.
KARA MILLER: Question over here.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to read from
the questions submitted online.
How significant is
industrial release methane
regarding climate change?
KARA MILLER: Industrial
release methane.
KERRY EMANUEL: It's
a very interesting--
KARA MILLER: So
first of all, what
is industrial release methane?
KERRY EMANUEL: So
just like CO2 is
a byproduct of certain
industrial processes,
methane can be.
And it's quantitatively a much
smaller problem to deal with.
One of the sources that you
consider industrial, I suppose,
is fracking.
So methane is used
a lot in fracking.
And in principle, it doesn't
have to get into the atmosphere
if you're careful.
But in practice,
a lot of it does.
So there's a big
push in science,
in coordination with industry
to try to reduce this problem.
But I think other than the
fracking, it is a problem.
Methane is going up
percentagewise almost
as fast carbon dioxide, but
quantitatively, so far, it's
not the magnitude of
the problem of carbon.
And the other side of it
is that when you do stop,
it goes away pretty quickly,
unlike carbon dioxide.
KARA MILLER: How
important to you
is it that regular are people
who are not scientists,
who are not politicians, who
are not necessarily involved
in this debate, understand
what's going on?
I mean, maybe it's
not that important
because they're not
going to be-- they're not
the policymakers and they're
not the people figuring out
what's happening in the climate.
To what extent are all of
us sort of bystanders here?
Should we know what's going on?
KERRY EMANUEL: Well, I
mean, my view of that
is that it's really great
to have, in any field,
to have a small
group of people who
study this, who try their
hardest to understand it,
climate scientists.
But on the other hand it's
unrealistic and perhaps
not even a good thing
to ask everybody
to become an amateur
climate scientist.
Sometimes I think that's
what people expect,
we expect of them.
That's not true at all.
I think you need to
understand two things well.
One, that there is a risk,
and that my community
is practically unanimous.
I mean, if you asked
biologists how many of them
believe that HIV causes
AIDS, maybe you get 97%,
but I doubt it.
I mean, 97% is a
spectacular number.
You don't have to have
all that much faith of it
if you start focusing on the
second thing, which I think
people ought to know more
about, is what the options are.
And here I think, not so much
my profession as the engineering
profession, haven't done the
best job in conveying to people
the whole spectrum of options.
There's the faction
that wants renewables.
Great, because that
will be part of the mix.
There's obviously the faction
who wants business as usual.
They want to keep burning coal.
And there's this
and that faction.
But what we really need to
look at is the whole range,
and to see not just risk
but opportunity, OK?
Quite apart from
climate change, there
are a lot of benefits that
would accrue to getting off--
particularly getting off coal,
which is estimated to result
in something like 10,000
premature deaths in the United
States every year.
Would we tolerate that from
any other energy source?
If nuclear did that, every
plant would be closed instantly.
But we tolerate that
because we're used to it.
We ought to be phasing those
out, going with renewables,
and developing, as I
say, next generation
fission and other things so
that we have a rational mix.
And we probably ought
to be doing that anyway.
I think that's where the
important debate-- I'd
like to change the axis
of the debate from,
is manmade climate
change occurring
or not-- which I think is
fruitless at this point,
although we still have to
do a lot of work on it--
to a different axis where
we talk about solutions
and argue in a
constructive way about what
those solutions should be.
KARA MILLER: It's interesting,
because in the most
recent Senate race,
Mitch McConnell,
obviously running to be Senate
Majority Leader, both he
and his opponent on
the Democratic side
were strong, strong proponents
of coal despite the fact
that fewer and fewer
jobs in Kentucky
are part of the coal industry.
But it was absolutely
crucial to both of them
that they be seen as the
top champion of coal.
KERRY EMANUEL: Well, I
think the long history
of American politics,
and probably politics
in many other places that we
have representative democracy,
representatives are going to
be arguing for their districts.
And if you're from
a coal district
you kind of have to do that.
I sort of sympathize with them.
But the rest of us don't
have to go along with that.
And if it's just those
two voices arguing,
and then the Democratic
person you're talking about
was not representing
the party on this,
eventually their voices
will be drowned out.
And this happens over and over
again in American politics.
KARA MILLER: Question over here.
AUDIENCE: Right.
My question is
basically, what can I do?
I listen.
I guess I could do
some Facebook activism,
but all my friends
already believe
in climate change,
so what's the point?
I vote.
What can I as an
individual, and what
can the average person
who agrees with you
and who follows you do?
KERRY EMANUEL: That's, I
think, an incredibly important
question.
And as an educator I ask myself
that-- now my students at MIT
ask me that question
quite a bit.
There are obviously
some things you
can do as a person to try to
be more conservation-minded.
And that's not so important
from the point of view
of how much energy
you actually save,
even if you sum up
over individuals,
it's little bit important, but
to change the cultural thinking
about climate.
But the other
thing, I think it's
terribly important
for young people--
and you look young to me,
although I'm blinded by light,
so I can't see you very
well-- to young people
to really be more vocal about
their concern about climate.
And you know, even if the
economics don't currently
weigh in favor of doing
anything about it,
politicians tend
to pay attention
when they realize that a younger
generation is really upset
about it.
I think this is how we
eventually, for example, got
out of Vietnam.
It wasn't from some geopolitical
argument as much as the fact
that young people
made it very clear,
finally, to their
parents' generation,
that they were unhappy
about the situation
and wanted it to change.
So I think being vocal in
that sort of political stage,
writing to your congressman,
organizing marches, you know,
that actually does make a
difference in the long run.
That's my view.
KARA MILLER: Another question.
AUDIENCE: I have a
similar question.
What can my employer do?
And specifically, Google has
a tremendous amount of power,
computational power, money in
the bank, billions of people
use us every day.
We also operate under
very strong constraints.
We have to make money
and we have a mission
to organize the
world's information.
Given these
constraints, if I were
to give you some portion
of the power of Google
and tell you to use it as best
you could, what would you do?
KERRY EMANUEL: Ooh.
That's a really--
I'd probably have
to ask you some more questions
to answer that sensibly,
but I'll have a shot at it.
But let me preface it by saying
that MIT, as another, not
as big as Google, but
a big organization,
is asking itself that
question as a community.
And I'm part of something
called-- a committee that
was commissioned by the
president of MIT, Rafael Reif,
to start a climate
conversation at MIT.
And it's amazing how engaged our
students are now in this issue.
They're very--they ask
a lot of questions,
like the fellow who spoke before
you, about what can they do.
And one thing they're
pushing MIT to do very hard
right now is to clean
up their own backyard.
We're not a very an
energy-efficient campus at all.
I work in something called
the Green Building, named
not for the color or for it
being environmentally sound,
but after the donor.
And it's as far from
green as you can imagine.
It's a huge energy hog.
MIT doesn't even
know, it turns out,
very much about how
much electricity
individual buildings as opposed
to the whole campus use.
I think MIT should be a showcase
for innovation in energy,
and buildings in particular.
And maybe there's a niche
like that for Google,
that when it contemplates
building something,
for example, it could
try to showcase-- maybe
it spends a little bit more
to showcase-- energy-efficient
technology.
Buildings use about
a third of the power
that we consume in this country.
KARA MILLER: We talked
before we sat down
a little bit about this
idea of divestment, which
has been-- there's been
pressure at campuses
around the country, a lot
of pressure at Harvard,
to divest from companies that
burn a lot of fossil fuel.
But as you're saying,
that's a tough one
because where do
you draw the line?
What kinds of corporate
activities are OK?
Like let's say you
manufacture products,
and you have people
manufacturing them
in Bangladesh under not
that great circumstances.
That's OK, but, you
know, that a tough way
to sort of make that line.
KERRY EMANUEL:
We're probably going
to stage to debate at MIT,
probably internal to MIT,
but maybe streamed out, on this
divestment issue, because it
turns out to be much
more complicated.
And so we have big oil
companies pouring money
into research at MIT to
do things like figure
out how to bury
carbon in the earth.
Do we want that to shut off?
I don't think so.
But on the other hand,
there are some things
you probably could divest from.
It turns out that a very small
percentage of MIT's portfolio
is wrapped up in fossil
fuel companies, for example.
But there's a flip side, too.
Instead of talking
about divestment,
we could also talk
about the investment.
That is, MIT could strategically
start a sort of subportfolio
that deliberately
tries to invest
in energy innovation, green
technology, and so forth.
So we can also take the
positive side of that
and maybe run with it a bit.
KARA MILLER: Question here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
I think your book
captures really
well the complexity
of the weather system.
And I think over
the last 50 years
we've done a great job
of understand really
complex systems.
I'd put the world
economy and physiology
of the human body
in those categories.
And I think what we've
learned is, as much as we know
about them, we're
still a long way away
from having the effects that we
want on them in a positive way,
and truly, deeply
understanding them.
And your book comments
about chaos theory
being a part of the
challenge with weather.
I'm just wondering, if
you had a magic wand
and actually had a technological
solution to greenhouse gases,
and you therefore weren't
dependent on social change
and all those effects, and you
also had the political will
to actually apply
that magic wand,
I'm wondering whether
we're prepared to have
that kind of power and
utilize it effectively given
that changes have all
sorts of uncertain effects
that we have a very
difficult time dealing with?
KERRY EMANUEL: That's
a fascinating issue.
I wish I could give you
a wise answer to that.
I have always
thought that wisdom
is the quality of
understanding just
the depths of your own
ignorance on something.
And believe me,
climate scientists
have become very well
acquainted with their ignorance
on the subject.
Your question is particularly
pertinent to solutions
that are on the table and have
been proposed that are broadly
called geoengineering, in which
we try to compensate for carbon
dioxide by blocking sunlight.
And we actually
literally could start
doing it both technologically
and economically right now.
We can pump sulphur
to the stratosphere.
We know how to do that.
It's not even that expensive.
But we don't want to
do that because we're
so familiar with our ignorance,
if you will, of the system
that we can give a pretty good
estimate what will happen.
But we wouldn't be too
surprised if we were wrong.
So there's all sorts of things.
If I had a magic
wand right now, I
would implement a
stiff carbon tax
and let the market, science,
engineering kind of work
it out, because I think
we're so close to being
able to pull carbon back out
of the atmosphere, which is not
so dangerous, because
we're just reversing damage
that we've already done.
KARA MILLER: Question here.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for coming in.
I don't really care
about the causation
versus correlation factor.
This is the only place I'm
going to live in my lifetime.
And every generation
that I can foresee
is going to be on this planet.
So I'm wondering,
though-- you had
talked a little bit
about the carbon tax.
I grew up in Canada.
Even the price of gasoline is
quite a bit higher than here.
And you're not an economist, but
being around this topic, what's
your sense of how much we are
subsidizing our contributions
to making this planet worse by
artificially lowering energy
costs in this country?
I don't know if that makes
does that make sense?
KERRY EMANUEL: I think
it makes perfect sense.
I mean, this is
exactly the first thing
you'd want to do, even
before you do carbon,
is stop subsidizing
fossil fuels.
I understand that
in the United States
our subsidies for fossil fuels
are greater than our subsidies
for renewables at the moment.
And the conservatives say
they don't like government
subsidizing one
industry over another.
And yet we're doing this.
It's something that
both sides of the aisle
ought to be able to
agree on at this point,
is stop subsidizing.
And what better time
to stop subsidizing
than when the price is
already low, as it is now?
So absolutely we
should stop doing that.
A carbon tax on top of
that, maybe gracefully
implemented over
some period of time--
and it doesn't actually
even have to be a tax.
It can be something--
in fact, I think
this might be proposed
here in Massachusetts,
is a-- I don't remember
exactly what it's called,
but you give the money
back to people in some--
so it's not a net
revenue source.
It's another way to do that so
you don't have call it a tax.
In fact, it wouldn't be a tax.
But just to
stimulate innovation.
I have high hopes
that Massachusetts
may become the first state in
this country have a carbon tax,
or some kind of fee on carbon.
KARA MILLER: Let's take
these two questions.
You want to just
ask your question
one right after the
other, and then you
can tackle both
at the same time.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I wanted to understand
a little more what
you're saying about hurricanes.
You talked about the
increased greenhouse gases
increasing the
atmospheric potential.
It sounds like you're
saying that that's
going to necessarily lead to
increased hurricane activity.
So you're saying that
there'll be more hurricanes,
or there'll be
greater intensity,
or how do we think about that?
KARA MILLER: And then-- yeah.
Let's get the second
question in too.
AUDIENCE: I have a very
different question.
I had this whole
fantasy last night
where the Koch
brothers, who are now
saying that they're going to
commit about a billion dollars
to the presidential campaign,
and are doing that largely
to fight efforts to deal
with global warming.
These guys give-- you know,
they built a building over there
at MIT.
They're giving money-- one
of them, or both of them
are MIT grads.
KARA MILLER: I think
just one of them.
KERRY EMANUEL: One of them is.
AUDIENCE: My fantasy is that
we bring them back to MIT
and we say, OK, let's
sit down and have
a discussion about this.
Here are the researchers
here in our community
who are doing what we
think is best work related
to global warming, and
try to set them straight.
Now perhaps that's unrealistic.
But I think my
question is, really,
is there-- do we
think there's really
a disconnect in the scientific
community, disagreements
over global warming?
Do we think that argument-- or
disagreements over human causes
of global warming-- do we think
that argument is settled now,
and there is merely a
political disagreement?
Do we need to bring
people together
to really understand
what the causes are?
And would educating the Koch
brothers make a difference?
KERRY EMANUEL: Really, they're
both very good questions.
I'll try to take them in order.
The evaporative
potential increase--
there's a speed
limit on hurricanes.
In a given atmosphere
ocean combination,
the energetics of hurricanes
puts a speed limit on them.
If you put more carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere,
you raise the evaporative
potential and the speed limit
goes up.
Now very few hurricanes
get up to the speed limit.
But what it means when we do
a more detailed study of it
is that, indeed, we see more
of the high-intensity events
when we put carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere,
or any other greenhouse gas.
But what happens to the far
more numerous, but far less
damaging, weaker events, there's
not a strong agreement on.
The other thing I
should say as an
aside is there's
a lot of agreement
that the average hurricane
will produce a lot more rain.
That's very, very basic physics.
And that's of concern because
a great deal of people
are killed in
fresh water floods.
So to go on to the
second question,
I think I learned a great
deal from a conversation
I had a few years ago with
an ex-Republican congressman
from South Carolina,
Bob Inglis-- who
was a rare conservative
Republican who did take climate
change seriously--
that what was stopping
his colleagues from believing
it was not because we
scientists are necessarily
all that poor at communication
or that there haven't been
efforts to reach these people.
It was that they were so
afraid of the solutions,
that they were going to be
solutions they couldn't buy.
The science really wasn't
the issue, it turned out.
And I thought that
was a very profound--
and I've tried to
go-- last year I
went to talk in a single meeting
to the heads of the American
Enterprise Institute, the
Competitive Enterprise
Institute, and the Heritage
Foundation, after promising
myself, I think for
Lent, that I wouldn't
stop preaching to
the converted and go
into the heart of territory.
And it was a very
interesting conversation.
And I sort of steered them
away from, is this is happening
or is it not?
I presented a little bit
of evidence, as in my book.
And I just tried
to steer it to, you
know, what about
solutions to this?
And I said, we aren't
having the kind of debate
we should have about how we're
going to solve this problem.
You guys got to get
into that debate.
And I sort of got them
excited about that-- I
tried to get them excited
about that debate.
By the end of the
conversation they said, yeah.
And it sort of got
lost in the background.
But they must have been
conscious of it at some level,
because if they start
to get involved in this,
they've tacitly admitted that
there's a problem to solve.
I don't know if I want to do the
Koch brothers because they're
so wrapped up in the particular
problem of fossil fuel.
They're defending
their own interests,
although one day I might.
KARA MILLER: I think
David Koch, who
is the main donor at MIT--
I could be wrong about this,
I'd have to Google it-- but I
think that David Koch has said
that he doesn't necessarily not
believe in climate change, i.e.
that he may believe
in climate change.
It's just that he has
business interests that
would be against a carbon tax.
It's not necessarily that he
doesn't believe the science.
Now I'd have to
double check that.
But I think that
may be true of him.
So as you said, it may be much
more of a financial incentive
rather than, of there
was only an explanation,
like some form of explanation
that would be effective.
Last question right here.
AUDIENCE: This
isn't my question,
but I just wanted to mention
that British Columbia already
has a carbon tax.
And it is, in fact, a
revenue-neutral carbon tax.
I don't know quite what
they do with the money.
I think they use it to
reduce other kinds of taxes.
But in any case,
there is that example.
I could certainly see maybe
some progressive state the US
adopting such a thing at some
point, get a ball rolling.
But anyway, my
question actually is
about conservation, which we
haven't talked too much about.
For example, my understanding is
that Germany has invested a lot
in passive solar housing,
much better insulated housing.
That kind of thing's probably
been pretty important.
I know as a homeowner I
don't do as much as I would
if I had more economic incentive
to do it, like a carbon tax.
But I'm certainly
aware of a bunch
of stuff I could
do in my own house.
It just-- my intuitive
sort of understanding
is that we have a huge way to
go in just conservation alone,
and that could potentially
be a huge source of savings.
But could you comment on that?
KARA MILLER: Conservation
is the unsexy portion
of talking about the climate.
KERRY EMANUEL:
But it's something
that we're in control of, right?
If you own a house or
you are contemplating
buying a car or
anything else, you
can control that to some extent.
And I think you're absolutely
right that the average person
is going to respond,
at some level,
to incentives and disincentives
to do this sort of thing.
And buildings are about a
third of the power consumption,
vehicles another third.
Industry is, I think--
very, very rough numbers.
So if you can beat these down,
it can make a big difference.
And we costed out at MIT,
what would it actually cost
us to comply with the gold
standard green regulation
in building a new building?
And the funny thing is,
we surveyed our students
and faculty about what they
thought the cost excess would
be, and it ranged
from 20 to 70%.
The actual numbers are
very close to zero.
And that sort of
surprised me, too.
And it turns out that
they're close to zero
because if you have more
insulation, more energy
efficiency, you're
generating solar,
you don't need to buy as
big a ventilation system,
for example.
There are cost savings.
And when you sum it all up,
it's pretty close to zero.
And I think when
more people find out
that they can do all
this at very little cost
to themselves-- and
of course, over time,
a big economic
benefit-- it's going
to happen in a more
widespread way.
KARA MILLER: Thank you for
your wonderful questions.
Thanks to Kerry
Emanuel for letting us
into the world of climate
scientists for an hour.
I'm sure he'll stay
for a few minutes
if you have other questions
that didn't get answered.
Thank you very much to
Google and Steve and Carly
for organizing.
Thanks.
KERRY EMANUEL: Thank you.